okay it shows that we are live test test
test
hey everybody hit hit a one in the
comments if you can hear me and see me
good this is my first time doing this uh
streaming at both times
let's see
shows that it's not going on YouTube
what's up baby
all right that's a one yeah so we're
totally live who's watching me from
YouTube and who's watching me from
Rumble
this is my first time ever
I didn't hit the all right perfect I see
I see there's a slight lag I'm gonna let
people come in here hey you got me on
Rumble showing
and on YouTube
right on okay so sound check let me see
a one if you guys hear me real good and
then we're gonna get underway is more
people filter in guys I have so much to
share with you I just got back from
balbec a couple days ago I went from
balbec to Egypt again
and I saw the most incredible things
I've seen in my life I am absolutely
convinced that balbeck the foundational
stones of the heliopolis are Smoking Gun
evidence for a lost ancient Advanced
Civilization now not everyone will agree
with that but I'm going to be showing
you I have the whole streaming software
set up so I can show you all the photos
that I took I have a little presentation
to share with you and I have some major
announcements to share about things I've
been working on these last few months uh
and you guys are gonna be blown away all
right I'm seeing a bunch of ones that
means it sounds good and looks good so
this is my setup temporarily guys so
here's the deal I just signed a deal
with Rumble I'm going to be doing live
streams with them so just to clarify I'm
still on YouTube I will be having all my
regular videos in fact more of them you
guys have seen in absence and videos but
when when you hear what I've been
working on you'll understand uh but I'm
going to be doing regular live streams
so I'll be doing three live streams a
month plus one live q a on locals so
essentially for a month I'll be doing
one a week uh and it's gonna be great
I'm gonna try and stagger them to where
when I come out with a video I'll have
the live stream following it up like the
next day so that way you guys can ask a
bunch of questions and we can like
reassess based on things because like
every time I make a video the very next
day people will comment on it and I'll
learn something new so it's going to be
a lot of fun to do it that way
um this is my setup here in my house for
now I'm gonna be playing with it so it's
probably gonna look different every
single time I do it but what do you guys
think of this
right I'm also going to get a different
microphone if this one sounds great
that's fine but I really if I'm going to
do it I'd rather have the top of the
line stuff
but anyways let me show you guys real
quick
boom so you can see me like this can you
see it on your end
can you see that I just updated the
background
give it a second and see if that picture
updates
it shows sweet so I'm gonna be going
through on my slides here
and you'll be able to see all kinds of
good stuff but okay so some updates
people are still filtering in so give me
just like a minute uh before I comment
you know on some of the stuff I'm going
to share just because you know a few
hundred more people are coming hey Chris
Gregory or Gregor is how do you say that
thanks for the yellow Super Chat hey if
anyone has any uh burning questions
throw me a Super Chat uh and I'll I'll
definitely notice it uh thank you to
John but I also don't want to like run
my live stream where I'm like saying
like I'm interrupting myself and saying
thank you every time it comes up because
I've watched enough live streams with
other YouTubers to see that that can
actually get annoying everyone else is
just watching and listening so I'll be
cognizant of that okay so updates first
of all I'm gonna be on a television
appearance on November 3rd so are you
familiar with the TV show The
Unexplained with William Shatner so let
me just say I don't have cable I don't
watch a lot of TV I watch Like
documentaries and stuff I mean I of
course Netflix and Prime and a couple
other ones but like
so I don't have cable TV so I'm going to
go to my parents house to watch it which
is hilarious but on Friday November 3rd
they are doing an episode on the rich
not structure and they invited the one
and only to come speak on it I'm gonna
be talking well I can't spoil anything
um but I'm just looking forward to
hilarious it's like my first television
appearance so it's looking fun about it
well they flew me out to Los Angeles for
the appearance and in the process like
it was divine timing so I've recently
connected with Graham Hancock for the
first time believe it or not we hadn't
met all these last number of years and
so it just so happened that so here's
the deal I'm gonna be speaking at a
conference this October 20th through the
22nd in Palm Springs it's called CPAC
um it is the conference for precisional
uh presidential change and ancient
knowledge it's gonna be awesome I'll be
there Graham Hancock will be there uh
Christopher Dunn will be there Robert
Edward Grant a whole number of people in
fact I have a link in the description so
if you would like to go
um I don't get Edition this is not like
a paid plug it's just that I'm going to
be there I'm already signed up to go I'm
going to speak for 50 minutes uh it's
going to be awesome and but if you're
interested there's a there's a link Down
Below in the description use the coupon
code ancient wisdom you get 100 off it's
a pricey like it's 500 bucks but this is
a chance for people to come rub
shoulders with all of us well I'll be
there we'll be hanging out and so if
that's something you guys want to do
it's going to be a real good vibe
anytime you go to an event like this
you're gonna be with other like-minded
people it's one of those rare
circumstances where you have a bunch of
I'd say nerdy which is a term of
endearment for me but the same room
doing the same thing there to seek more
information and knowledge about our past
and other interesting things so if that
interests you awesome uh but let me keep
going along
I have a lot of things to share
so I have been working on now I can't
share too much because I've been told
not to and I signed a deal but I am
working with a production company I'm
doing a documentary at the wrist shot
structure
they are looking to to do a serious job
on this one it's going to uh require a
lot of resources I can't share the angle
on on what we're going for here I've
been asked to just leave it alone we're
currently pitching it there's a whole
process involved but I've been working
on this heavily for the last number of
months and here's the best part because
like whenever you hear these things like
with television appearances like you
don't have any rights to it you have no
creative control like for example with
the show The Unexplained we'll talk
about the wrist shot structure they
could edit that any way they please now
the way the ques the questions and
everything out of my mouth because I was
aware of it going in there's no doubt on
my mind that it's gonna look favorable
upon me there was no questions or
anything that I said that's gonna like
try to make me look like a fool uh so
with that being said with this
documentary I am going to be an
executive producer which gives me
creative rights and I would have it no
other way so stay tuned this is going to
be a long process it may never even see
the light of day but I'll keep you guys
posted as I go but I couldn't be more
excited and what's so wild about this is
that the producer uh for the production
company after my last Joe Rogan
appearance back in January this
gentleman was in a car to go to the
airport and the Uber driver was
listening to Rogan so the the they start
listening to it this guy is listening to
me rattle off you know the concentric
circles free water to have land red
black white color Stones you know
opening the sea at the South yada yada
and he was like so he Googles it and
he's like how have I never seen heard of
this before and this is my point I've
said this 100 times
every time I meet new people and they
ask what I do and I start having a
conversation I'll pull out my phone and
I'll show them a picture of the wrist
shot structure from space I have never
once met anybody that has seen or heard
of it before there's only one exception
or two exceptions people that like
recognize me I've been recognized out in
public and people like you know so they
would have known uh but one of The
Producers when I was filming uh The
Unexplained in Los Angeles said that he
was familiar with the site because he
plays civilization six the the PC game I
used to play Civilization five lot great
game anyway
uh he said that the restaurant
structures in Civilization sticks but
what he had never heard of is the
comparison to Plato's description of the
lost city of Atlantis so uh lots of fun
um hey Rado thanks for the uh 20 bucks I
appreciate the kind words as well okay
so how many people we got in here we're
moving along so let me just keep going
guys I'm gonna start showing you some
photos of this stuff but I wanted to
list off some other announcements
because like you haven't seen a number
of videos in a while and I have a couple
amazing ones cooking uh one is involving
some lost mats I won't say of where but
it's like
it's gonna be it's gonna
it's gonna get people thinking
um but also I had an appearance on Tim
Poole IRL uh many people will know who
he is uh he flew me out to Maryland I
did it on a Friday night uh was it two
weeks ago three weeks ago uh so go to
timpool IRL on or Tim cast IRL excuse me
on YouTube and you'll see me on there
and I had a conversation with a few
awesome guys uh you might like it uh it
was a lot of fun I hope to do it again
let's see what else I got going on here
I already mentioned the conference if
you guys are interested in coming the
link is down below
um let's see what else here
um oh yeah yeah like I was just saying I
met Graham Hancock so the gentleman
Walter crudenden is putting on the
conference in Palm Springs and this guy
is an absolute gentleman I am so
grateful for the invite to come speak
and because of it the Divine timing like
I was saying a minute ago is that the
night before I was flying out to Los
Angeles for the filming of The
Unexplained I get a random email from
Walter he said Hey listen or it actually
was a couple days earlier but he said
Hey listen uh are you available on this
date at this time Grim Hancock is going
to be here in town and we're going out
to dinner you're invited and I was like
oh my God I'm flying out in just a
couple days and that's the night before
I'm supposed to film in Los Angeles so
the production people were amazing and
they literally rerouted my flight
because I was going to fly into Los
Angeles the very night that I was having
dinner which
I never told anyone this but it was my
birthday my birthday is June 5th so like
I didn't even tell Graham Hancock he
doesn't know I wasn't about to tell them
that I was linking up with them for
dinner on my birthday because for me the
fact that I was flying out to Los
Angeles for this television appearance
my birthday to me is fun like I don't
even care about my birthday I don't
celebrate it it's always friends with
family that want to like go do something
but for me I'm like
I just I don't know I don't like things
being about me believe it or not some
people won't believe that because I lose
Guys YouTube channel uh but I don't like
I just it just makes me feel
uncomfortable and I just to me every day
is my birthday every day should be a
celebration sounds cheesy but it's kind
of my spiritual philosophy of things
anyway so yeah I had gram uh Dan with
Graham Hancock on my birthday and it was
a ton of fun the guy's a total gentleman
like I didn't know totally what to
expect like everyone I know that's Venom
loves them
um but I'm like you know it's mildly
intimidated because I'm like look this
be real this guy has been studying these
topics for like over 30 years traveling
around the world I have so much I can
learn from him there's so many things
that he's shared that like different
things I look back in my videos over the
years that I've gotten wrong little
details there so it's like to me I'm
like I you know this guy's like my
teacher so I was I was really interested
and curious to see what it'd be like
when I met him and we hit it off uh I
hit off with his wife santha who's a
sweetheart a total she lights up the
room she loves to laugh and she's a good
time uh so anyways I thought that would
be fun to share you guys uh you know
some of you would have known so people
who follow me on social media Instagram
go follow me there I guess if you care
about me enough like Instagram such
trash like they recently censored one of
my posts talking about the Constitution
um so like Mark Zuckerberg is absolute
trash like I guys when it comes to
freedom of speech there's this is the
only way and this is one reason why I'm
partnering with Rumble as I'll tell you
but um as I'm going down my little
tangent here follow me on Twitter though
I've really upped my presence on there I
love it since Elon has took over I know
not everyone's an Elon fan but I am a
fan and a champion of anyone or a fan of
anyone that is a champion for freedom of
speech guys
throughout history like this goes in
because a lot of people will say oh
don't stay away from uh politics Jimmy
focus on the Ancients I'm like I feel
and I mean this with respect like I feel
like a lot of people don't even know
what the word politics means by politics
are you talking about like history are
you talking about current events are you
talking about like history repeats
itself and there has been a common
denominator throughout history which is
that people who suppress others those
who are tyrants about Free Speech are
always the bad guys and if you're not
paying attention it's pretty obvious to
me that that we are in a cycle that's
repeating itself that if you look at
what happened to the Romans the ancient
Greeks
um Revolutions in China like it is to me
we are witnessing things that were
happening 100 years ago recirculate and
and the reason why history repeats
itself is because humans haven't changed
we're wired a certain way we are a
flawed species in many ways or at least
the people who want to run the show are
and
um so anyways yeah so with that being
said
uh and I know I'm all over the place
because I'm having a good time uh but
follow me on Rumble Rumble is a
alternative platform to YouTube and many
many other YouTubers who have been
censored are migrating over to rumble
because they are definitive on freedom
of speech they are they are absolute on
it and they have been very very good to
me they're promoting me there
um and so some people like oh they're an
ALT right uh website I'm like what is no
like that's silly it just so happens
that although all right people so to
speak got censored but you guys need to
know I gotta I got a strike on my
channel a community guideline strike
from a video I had made in 2017
talking about Ashton Kutcher addressing
Congress on the topic of of sex
trafficking
let that sink in years later they give
me a strike on my channel
three and you're gone so it's like first
of all it's unbelievable to me and I
appealed it denied
so I have to cover my ass like I have
got to put my ducks in a row I cannot
rely on YouTube and besides that it's
time for me to start living my best life
and become who I was born to be in this
online realm I have held back the reason
why you guys haven't seen videos on a
regular basis is because I'm watching
the world
go heading into a great Calamity for so
many reasons not just economic but like
uh uh macro economic or macro turmoil
across the whether it's China and all
these other things like all this the
live Ukraine like it's hard to know
where to begin all the lies that we've
heard in the last few years involving uh
the ma pandemic like if you want to even
call it that like guys I've been
watching what's going on and the feeling
that I've had to bite my tongue out of
fear of censorship aggravates me and
upsets me like no other I have like a
scattered brain as you could probably
tell just for listen to me talk here I'm
an excitable person so like I'll be
working on the video like a few months
ago it's supposed to be done on the
video on these lost maps of a certain
place that are gonna blow you away but
as I'm watching other things happen in
the world my attention goes that way and
I want to make a video on this but I'm
like well I need to finish this video
and then something else happens in the
world I'm like oh my God I need to tell
everyone what's going on so the long
story short is that I haven't done that
because I'm like they're gonna censor me
okay because even the topic of climate
change so one of the the pleasures I had
when I was on Tim Poole was that I
wanted to give a brief little
presentation so to speak a little uh you
know to talk about how the Sahara Africa
I believe I believe debunks the man-made
climate change agenda that's going on
today keyword agenda I'm not some
because people immediately like oh he's
anti-science he's saying humans aren't
destroying the world hey hang on a
second I remember during all the
lockdowns how all of a sudden the Skies
over Los Angeles cleared up I remember
during the lockdowns at the canals of
Venice all of a sudden were clear and
dolphins had returned I saw those things
I also know that like if I'm driving
around or let me say walking my dog and
in the morning and people will be going
to drive to their jobs and they drive by
and they smell their exhaust teams my
body feels repelled when I smell it I
don't like it so like
what I'm about to say next is this that
when it comes to the agenda there are
powers that be out there that want to
take your tax money to fight carbon and
it's not going to do anything it's
nothing but a power shift but this the
climate change thing is going to be the
next thing that's going to have
tyrannical control just today the UN
Secretary General was talking about how
they need social media platforms across
C2 now go after people that are
spreading dangerous climate
misinformation
what notice how in these climate change
discussions by the way I'm going to be
talking about ball back in a second to
everyone tuning in but I need to get
this off my chest
notice how in these man-made climate
conversations we never talk about the uh
Roman warming period of 2000 years ago
when there was an abundance of wine
vineyards uh Roman wine vineyards in the
UK
a lot of people don't know that there
was warming throughout the Northern
Hemisphere different regions of the
northern hemisphere that say including
the Mediterranean and they believe it's
related to the Sun by the way
then fast forward between the years 1350
and 1850 approximately there was a
550-year window called the little Ice
Age Google it there was Global famine
particularly in the northern hemisphere
a reduction of livestock increased
disease and it's related now there's
several different hypothesis one of
which we believe is partly related to
the sun could have been some other
volcanic stuff some of it's debatable my
point is this
where do these things how come I never
hear these things in the content in the
conversation of man-made climate change
what about these Cycles we are in the
middle of an ice age that has been going
on for three million years and what we
know through ice core data is that over
the last 450 000 years there's been five
interglacial periods which means there's
been five periods of warming where the
glaciers recede and then they go back
and they go down and up and back and
forth and the data shows that the Earth
is cold more often than it's hot and let
me tell you how serious this is some of
these same same things that I said on
Joe Rogan in January fast forward a few
months and all these videos of that
podcast which I thought went really well
by the way leave a comment if you
thought the podcast well last time I
thought went way better than my first I
was far less nervous
um but
Tick Tock videos of going around I don't
make Tick Tock videos I'm not on Tick
Tock
um but
a bunch of people like parceled out and
millions of clips and some of them got
like 20 million views being talking
about the pole shifts and other things
so if you're not familiar there's an
organization called Media Matters and
they started going after me and Rogan me
talking about I'm spreading
misinformation on Tick Tock I'm like
first of all I'm not on Tick Tock second
of all the clips you shared are based on
scientific evidence and I sent this
reporter literal studies from MIT and
everything else and she didn't include
any of them in her in her
um article and not even gonna cite the
article because it's crap and who cares
and nobody cares
um but I kind of had fun with it but the
point is is that these powers that be
are now aggressively going to go after
people that talk about anything climate
change and how am I supposed to talk
about the green Sahara how am I supposed
to talk about Atlantis like they're
gonna come after me they're going to
come after everybody see this is how
tyrannical control works evolving
censorship it will all come down to the
state the state will be the only one has
authorized teachers and they are going
to go after everybody at least anyone
that's teaching anything they're already
making moves the reason why they were
going after the Rogan Clips is because
they want to try and get Rogan Clips
banned off tick tock
these people are insane so going back to
rumble and why you should follow me
there first of all I've already seen
comments when I've like advertised my
new Rumble and people you know forget it
I'm not doing it I'm like
guys
are you oops I said that
r-u-m-b-l-e.com like I'm not asking you
to drive down the street I'm not asking
you to get an Uber fare for Christ's
sake
um you know you type in rum and it's
going to pop up you don't even have to
you have to have a signed an account on
your mobile
on on TC you don't but like it's no
different than you going to YouTube like
so if you really support me and you want
to see my my best work come to light
follow me there but but again my regular
videos will be uploaded to YouTube I'm
simply going to be doing live streams on
Rumble and I will usually start it off
just like I am here which is that I will
be on YouTube and then Midway through
the stream I'll say hey guys if you want
to watch the rest of this and hear the
amazing stuff come follow me on Rumble
and guess what you can see the link in
the description down below is the
easiest thing ever you don't have to do
anything except for click I'm just I
know a lot of people are hearing this
book yeah no big deal I'll do it but
there's always it's the internet so some
people are like I'm not going to rumble
shut up come on
um okay so hold on a second let me just
see before I start showing you some
amazing photos
let me just double check to see if I
have any pending
um super chats I guess if anyone has an
amazing question fired out now
because I'm about to my f you with these
photos
okay
first of all let me tell you something
I'm really excited about involving where
I just went
so actually let me give this person a
shout out so while I was inside the
Temple of Bacchus in balbec on the
platform of the heliopolis I got a thing
a notification on my phone
from someone called lennae that gave me
five dollars on locals so I just meant
to I meant to plug them as well
uh locals is an alternative to patreon
and they're also all about the freedom
of speech so support me there you don't
have to pay anything but with if you do
give me like a monthly you know fee
whatever it is you can do a dollar you
can find you do as much as you want or
as little as you want you'll have
special access to some stuff so let me
plug that to while I'm at it but anyways
this person whoever lynnae is if you're
listening you popped up while I was the
middle taking phone uh photos of
photographs and ball back so I took a
screenshot of it because I'm like this
means a lot to me I'm going to give this
this person a shout out so thank you so
let me keep going we got like 2 000
people watching give me a second here
let me just double check this
you have to give me like multiple tabs
open so I got a 2084 on YouTube and I
got
1021 on Rumble holy crap so I got a
total of like over 30 almost 300 people
watching
um that's amazing Okay so
let me get
so check this out do you recognize
somebody there let me show you another
photo here actually let me go back on
the left is obviously me next to me is a
gentleman named Pierre then that's to
the right of him is George Saint Pierre
also known as GSP and to the right of
him is a gentleman named Dory so I had
the pleasure of traveling to Baltic
Lebanon and Beirut uh as well as Egypt
with George Saint Pierre uh and these
gentlemen here uh one of the only guys
I'd have to say the only thing more wild
than the topic of lost ancient
civilizations
is the diverse nature of the types of
people that are into these topics so I'm
not a name dropper I don't like the
whole clout thing so like I like I've
met up with interesting people and I
won't take a picture and put it online
because I just think that it's rude I
just feel like
I want to know you as a person I don't
want to like be the guy it's like hey
look at me
um but in this circumstance with all the
traveling uh George and I were both
excited to share this stuff and so we
connected and he had been following my
channel and I've been following him for
many years because I watched him
fighting when I was in Iraq in 2010 I
remember 2009 or 2010 was one of his
fights that I saw because he got all
three pay-per-view out there and so it's
surreal to have connect with them years
later we're both fans of each other so
to speak and and so he's like hey I'm
going to Beirut and balbec as well as
Cairo do you have any suggestions on on
travel stuff and I said well I don't
have any connections in fallback I can
hook you up in in Cairo uh and I'm gonna
be shouting out Yusuf Ariana in a moment
who gave us an amazing tour
um but in in Beirut in balbec so long
story short the Pierre that you see here
as well as Dory uh Pierre is from
Lebanon he now lives in Canada and Dory
still lives
and
um uh appears The Godfather and George
saying here I should be sharing this let
me just let me just move on from that
point but the long story short is that
these gentlemen had connections in the
country and so I was able to come along
with because ballbeck has been on the
the top of my list
I had Egypt Peru and balbec and then
after that is Petra that I wanted to go
to more than any other place and I I
still haven't been to Rome but that's
that's in in the works uh pretty soon
actually uh but anyways my point is that
balbec is a place that can be a little
bit sketchy like it is certain parts of
it are extremely safe like I felt Beirut
was absolutely wonderful but balbeck is
in Hezbollah controlled region of
Lebanon so like that is in short a bit
complicated
um so let me keep going here I'm going
to show you guys some pictures because I
know a lot of you are waiting but check
that out like I don't know how many of
you are into mixed martial arts at UFC
um but to do a Face-Off with George was
one of the funnest things I've ever done
like just hilarious in its own way and I
have to say that this guy is one of the
most down-earth Swedish people I've ever
met total gentleman
um he is friendly to everyone he meets
uh it was wild traveling with him
because he got recognized everywhere
like he is one of the more famous people
around because people all over the world
are into the the sport of MMA and so it
was it was super fun to see him
interacting with fans we walk it up and
down the street the airport sitting at a
restaurant he got recognized at the
entrance of the Great Pyramid of Giza by
this this chick this girl like she was
like kept doing the Double Take and I
looked at her and I'm like it's him and
like because she was bringing up her
phone and anyway so it's just wild to
travel with him but let me get to it
because enough gushing over him but I
just want to tell the world just how
grateful I am for the opportunity that I
got to travel with him and if it wasn't
for him I wouldn't have had this
opportunity to go see Beirut because I
was waiting I'm like I need to do this
right
um and because of it I had the
connection in Cairo so I've given the
shout out before he gave me my first
tour in Egypt his name is Yusuf awion he
works for the uh uh chemist School of
ancient mysticism
um tours
um and there's a few other YouTubers
that that have traveled with him before
and I absolutely love him
um I will have a picture in here
somewhere I'll have to cut to it but I
don't want to skip around but um if
you're gonna go to Egypt guys this guy
gave us
or free he did it because we're his
friends but he gave us one of the most
spectacular tours I ever could have
imagined and because he grew up across
the street from the Sphinx literally his
house is still there it overlooks the
Sphinx he's on it's I don't see what
floor but he's right there and because
his father had it and his father was a
gentleman named Akeem Abdel awion and he
was in the the docu-series the pyramid
code
um and actually hold on one second one
second guys
okay I'm back hopefully you can hear me
um the pyramid code and so he's a super
interesting gentleman but anyways where
I'm trying to go with this is that if
you want a dope ass freaking tour of
Giza if you're gonna go there higher
Yusuf are we on he'll give you a fair
deal but not only that actually is way
less expensive than many of the others
like he's like half the price of zahi
you was tour like it's unreal like but
my point is is that he has these
connections and so the guards know him
out there on the plateau and because of
that I don't want to say too much on the
internet because I can put him in a
situation with the Antiquities
department but let's just say that we
all know how the real world works and if
you know people sometimes in life that
affords you certain opportunities you
know like things with keys and locks and
picture opportunities and places that
are forbidden I'm not saying I had that
opportunity
but
so keep that in mind he did us a real
solid and he blew uh gsp's mind he
absolutely blew his mind and that that
said a lot he uh I'm gonna have to show
you guys at some point I don't want to
like share too much because George is in
the process of sharing things on his
social media but I have video of him
going in to the Great Pyramid for the
first time so that was wild but
um let's see here someone said let me
just give a quick shout out to S thank
you for the 10 bucks and Davey Oneness I
have a book about to come out now you're
going to want to see how can you get a
copy email to me or guys hey man blast
it out to the internet and I'll uh on
Twitter and I'll I'll recirculate that
but send me an email it's in my
description but let me keep going guys
because this is a live stream
so what you're looking at here in this
photo
it's called the stone of the pregnant
woman it is approximately 1250 tons it
is 69 feet long and is 16 feet high by
16 feet wide and it was up until
recently the LA the the world's largest
Cuts excuse me the world's largest stone
ever cut and quarried and it's still
attached to the Bedrock it is said to
have been created by the Romans but
there's no evidence of that and believe
me I'm gonna debunk that here in just
the next few moments but keep look at
that photo and now look at me here
I'm five foot ten or 178 centimeters and
like I've said in my other videos
pictures do not do it justice like
you'll see I know you're smart and
you'll stare at this button aren't you
gonna but then when you see it with your
own eyeballs guys it's always different
it's
a behemoth it's so much bigger than this
picture I look at this picture and I'm
like this is a sad representation it's
not showing everyone what they really
need to see and just how amazing it is
there's GSP George joint beer uh
standing next to it now he's five foot
eleven just for perspective uh let me
keep going you can see here the where
it's the various cut marks and whatever
they were doing to scrape it out and how
it's still that's the Bedrock it's still
attached to
there's Pierre standing next to it from
the opposite end and as you can see in
this oh hold on dog barking don't worry
about it
um
see this I don't know if you can see my
mouse can you see my mouse in the in the
screen
probably not dang okay so you can see
the dirt line from left it's going
horizontally down to the right so up
until just a few years ago this was
completely buried up to that point and
when the UN when they dug it out they
found another Stone next to it which I'm
about to show you which is now the
largest stone ever cut
so let's see here
get ready for it all right so this is
from behind it get ready
boom now this picture in itself because
it's taken on Ultra wide lens it looks
super narrow but as you're gonna see
this thing is so much bigger than the
stone you just saw in these next few
photos so just to clarify
this stone is approximately 1 250 tons
same Stone
this stone is approximately eighteen
hundred times one thousand eight hundred
tons here you go
wait for it so it's just to the left
here so you're seeing it now in the the
opposite direction I was just facing
in fact let's see here
um so look directly to the left and you
can see this little uh hollowed out
Point that's the start of the stone now
wait for it
boom this is one more photo you're gonna
see a lot of other that's Dory standing
on it he's close to my height I would
say so it's significantly wider but wait
for it
that's the depth of it
so you'll see another photo on just how
wide it is but what you're not seeing
here because we didn't climb down
because we didn't want to like break our
legs because it's it looked real risky
and plus we were in a super rush which
is unfortunate but it's the nature of
the of life but this is so much this is
I don't have the dimensions but again
the other one the other Stone was 16
feet by 16 feet this one is
significantly wider and deeper than that
so standby you'll see some more photos
there's another one to give you a
perspective so it dwarfs dwarfs this
other Stone but I have more to show you
hold on so look at us there there's me
and George standing on it you get the
idea still mostly buried but this thing
again was completely submerged uh up
until just a few years ago so this Stone
I don't remember someone gave it a name
hey leave a comment if someone remembers
what they named this Stone and uh let's
see here you just see anyone has any
see how many people oh we got 1457
people watching on Rumble and we got
almost 2 400 people watching on YouTube
I love you all thank you all so much for
the support
um so let me keep going I'm seeing that
on YouTube does yours look blurry over
there
it looks crisp
I hope that doesn't look too blurry guys
I use I have Ultra 4K pictures on this
but anyways let me keep going
so there's us between the two stones the
1800 ton Stone and the 1250 ton Stone of
the pregnant woman as they call it
there's me and George standing next to
it guys
these stones
are so stupid big now let me just say
that I'm going to show you in a bit the
trilathon stones which are the 900 ton
stones that make up the foundation of
the heliopolis they're transported
almost a mile
and the Temple of Jupiter sits on top of
them those are the largest Stones ever
cut carved quarried moved and lifted as
you're going to see in a few minutes
um but
the reason why
they say that the uh the Romans did this
it just left them is that look well
after they cut them out they realized
they were too big to move
so they just slapped them
okay so I really don't like that that
silly hypothesis because it's like
they're not stupid whoever cut and
carved these and I don't believe it's
the Romans they're almost didn't cut
anything big go look at pictures of the
Coliseum
and as impressive as it is or even the
aqueduct as impressive as that is in the
advanced math and sophistication that
went into creating those amazing feats
of of engineering and
the stones aren't that big they don't in
fact they're all small stones
um and so as far as the Roman Empire
nothing even compares to this and I'm
going to tell you what the guides at the
site told us which is way different than
the academic version they say that it
was created by the Phoenicians they say
the Phoenicians created this site 4 000
years ago
um and by this site let me keep going so
you can see what I'm talking about but
um and that the Romans came after and
built on top of it and as the photos
you're going to see in this presentation
it's undoubtful it's so obvious that it
was created by two different
civilizations
um so let's see here
quick shout out to Thomas backstet what
did you see during your tours in the
military that set you down this path I
don't recall seeing explanation of
videos all right so I have to come back
to that Thomas but um I did see these
Wing Bulls called the lamasu in Northern
Iraq at the gates of Nagal and the
ancient biblical City but I was already
into the ancients from like the fifth
and sixth grade when I was reading those
Goosebump books by R.L Stine and they
were going in the pyramids but let me
keep going that's a great question and
I'm gonna make a video on it but I have
touched on it some other videos uh now
real quick here this is inside this
Quarry so if I didn't say that already
these two stones are located in the
Quarry which is approximately a mile
away from the Temple of Jupiter and the
the stones and the heliopolis that
you'll see
um and so these are other examples of
massive stones that were being cut and
carved out at that time
um okay so this like I told you ballbeck
is located in a Hezbollah controlled
region of Lebanon so a lot of people if
you're not familiar remember the
explosion that happened in Beirut three
four years ago now
that country has never recovered it's
heartbreaking oh I forgot to bring my
currency guys like a hundred thousand
Lebanese dollars is now worth a dollar
fifty
before the explosion it was down to like
16 50 16 and 50 cents U.S comparison uh
so that this country has gone through so
much stuff in the last number of decades
it's wild
um and you've as you may have seen in
one of my first photos uh just how
pretty it is so like that's Beirut right
there by the way look how green that
water is or blue green uh it's gorgeous
this is one of the prettiest countries
I've seen it blew me away blew me away
uh but my point is is that it never
recovered and now everything is
worthless and because of it a lot of
things have gotten a little dicey so
I have a few things to share involving
this one
guys me and George were of a similar
mindset like we ain't going anywhere
sketchy without like armed protection
but Dory himself who lives in Beirut is
the one that supplied this who escorted
us
um his family also escorted us because
they live not far away so like we had
like a little mini Convoy and so that
way if we got because you gotta
understand there's like checkpoints you
have the Christian checkpoints and then
you have the Hezbollah checkpoints it's
wild
let me say a couple things here
no I will not be going to ball back
without or that region without some sort
of armed protection for myself
or someone else that can protect me
however
not at any point not even for a split
second did I feel nervous once we got
out there everyone was nice they ex they
loved hers
zero issue whatsoever
but
not that long ago like but things do
happen so Dory has a friend now I don't
know how their whole auto insurance
policies work out there but people will
buy a car with cash and in this he had
traveled to that region
he got held up he said hey this is our
car now you come back in one week with
ten thousand dollars if you want your
car back otherwise you're out whatever
how much he paid for it I didn't even
ask what kind of car it was but he would
have been out you know out of it
so he went back a week later and gave
the people the ten thousand dollars he
came up with the money and got his car
back so like that wasn't even that long
ago so like so I want to hear things
like this guys like I wanna because I'm
trying to present this in a way that
says I really encourage you to go to
Beirut I encourage you to go to balbec
you will not regret it but be smart
about it like there's other people I
know they're going to be doing tours and
stuff out there so I'm sure they'll have
security or whatever
for me personally guys like that AKA
made me feel real good and that's not
the only firearm that we had
um and that stuff you can get that so
easy out there so like this wasn't you
know it wasn't a big deal but you know
when I was like advertising this for
people who follow me on social media
saying like hey guess where I'm going
and a lot of people are guessing like oh
he's going to Martini he's going the
Iowa Sahara yeah not yet but when I go
there I'll definitely have something as
well
um but yeah guys do you see those of you
who aren't familiar I'm an Iraq veteran
like I'm guys I believe in guns I carry
a gun everywhere in fact when I when I
start doing these regular live streams
I'm gonna be talking about all kinds of
different topics prepping I'll talk
about guns all kinds of fun stuff so if
you're into those things
um stay tuned but anyway so I had this
photo of it which I thought some of you
would enjoy
um okay
this is the formal entrance to the
heliopolis that leads into the Temple of
of Jupiter as well as the Temple of
Bacchus as you're going to see shortly
that's GSP with Pierre now you see these
five excuse me six
columns stone columns
that is Rose granite and you're not
going to believe this
that originates from Aswan Egypt some
like 800 miles away maybe like 700 miles
as the bird flies
these stones
were transported it may have been closer
to A Thousand Miles depending on the
road and this is according to mainstream
academics this isn't like some like
pseudo like oh you know these Stones
were brought across the world like
literally the academic safe did you read
any of the literature it says yeah this
is the Rose Granite that only originates
the only known place in the region that
originates is all the way down in Aswan
guys Aswan is the place where the
granite stones that make up the Great
Pyramid they were moved 500 miles away
you know I'm always making a big deal
about that and other people are making a
big deal about it you know how do they
get these 70 ton Stones 500 miles and
lifted 300 feet above the ground into
the king's chamber of the Great Pyramid
Guys these are like another a few
hundred miles further than that and
the academics will say that they moved
them across the Mediterranean too you
know they put them on two different
boats boats on the Nile and boats in the
ocean and the Mediterranean like
so you say uh I don't I don't really buy
that
um but any anyway
take that all in now this that's me
compared to a broken column that is not
Granite this is the Limestone that
originated in the Quarry not far away
um but look at the size comparison I'll
have other photos for you as well
um real quick let me just give a quick
shout out hey thank you Matt Bell for
the uh Super Chat and lost world CV
creep up the great work
um but look at the size of this guys
again like I'm five foot ten
and this thing is what another closer to
two feet higher than me
I'm gonna show you another photo I wish
I could zoom in on that is that okay
that didn't let me do it forget it
um look at that
there's me and George compared to
another column that's broken in half and
that's another thing that you guys are
going to be seeing here shortly is that
this place is littered with just broken
Stones like some sort of insane
cataclysm had transpired here the whole
place is half destroyed except for the
biggest stuff of them all which I
believe was created previously
um
let's see here
look at that
this is just an open area inside the
heliopolis all this is like 30 feet off
the ground so what you're real what you
need to understand is that we're on
um a platform an elevated platform like
I showed you a few slides ago those
States you go up so you go up the stairs
to get to here so it's like 30 feet up
and then the other temples you go up
more stairs too
um now let me just say that I'm gonna
some of you can all hate me but like I
was just telling you about Rumble it's
not hard for you guys to go follow me
there so in a few minutes here I'm gonna
have to cut this off to go to rumble
because I'm gonna do at least an hour
over there that's the arrangement I have
and I'll probably go longer on a regular
basis like to those of you who have been
following my channel for a while I've
done three hour podcasts or live past so
in a few minutes I'm gonna have to stop
and go over there so that way I have
plenty to show you because I have about
100 slides and I'm already at slide 27
but the most impressive stuff all the
most impressive things that you'll see
whether it's from the Temple of Bacchus
um and the trilathon stones uh that will
all be over there so let me see here
because I'm already 42 minutes in and I
also you'll hit me oh I don't want to go
over Rumble just do it the Link's in the
description you see it right there
that it's it's live over there right now
and so once I end the live stream here
on YouTube it will just uh continue uh
on on Rumble
simultaneously it'll be it'll be
continuous so hold on a second here I'm
going to show you a couple more things
before I do that
to do I got 2500 people watching here on
YouTube and I got
1700 people watching on Rumble guys I'm
so grateful that's a pretty good size
that's awesome I'm very grateful
um all right so hold on one second
because I gotta get something ready here
to show you
hey
hold on
sorry guys I'm toggling this is my first
time doing it so it's a little bit
different
hold on ask me someone asked me a good
question to distract me
let me know if you see any good
questions what are you seeing
how what
oh my God this is warmer was the best
they've ever had I never say is it shosh
armor it's just warmer literally the
best I've ever had in my life and let me
just say this actually
George Saint Pierre said the same thing
so one of his favorite foods is Lebanese
and where he's from Montreal they have
like a fantastic Lebanese restaurant
that he's been to a million times and
the restaurant that we went to on the
first night which is called
m khadif m kadif I believe
was I've never tasted anything like this
guys and even George himself said this
is literally the best Lebanese food I've
ever had and what I didn't realize guys
is that people throughout the region
like like in Egypt for example the
number one restaurant in Cairo is a
Lebanese restaurant which is kind of
funny
um this food was so freaking good and so
I had this like Shawarma one of the day
the second day I had this Shawarma
sandwich but it's basically like a
burrito as far as like an American uh as
it goes and this thing was so loaded
with flavor I cannot believe it it was
the best thing I've ever tasted
um
so let's see here guys give me one
second here I'm just figuring something
out because I'm technologically
illiterate
um all right so I think I may have
figured it out hold on
hold on
okay anyways let me go show you some
more photos so I'm not boring you guys
all right so hopefully a bunch of people
carried on over to go follow me on
Rumble because I'm saying that the
numbers went down by about 500 so
hopefully they're over there all right
so that's what I'm going to do I'm going
to show you guys another photo and I'm
gonna bounce because I know I have to do
it so check this out real quick before I
do that start following me over on
Rumble because you'll be able to see me
over there
continuously now
see these stairs over here on the upper
right
and you see the blocks to the left of it
wait for this
hold on ignore that see those blocks
these are all estimated at 400 tons a
piece and there's like nine of them that
go right down the lane
um okay so I'm at the 45 minute Mark
what I'm going to show you guys next is
even far more impressive because I
almost feel heartbroken that I'm about
to like say bye on YouTube and go over
to rumble but this is what it is and
this is all the more reason to come
follow me over there the rest of this
video is going to be the most
interesting things of it all I'm so
great everyone tuned in here on YouTube
the link to watch right now is down in
Rumble so just press it right now and
you'll be able to hear me uh
continuously and but anyways I want to
just give you all my love and thank you
so much my video is coming out here in
less than a week it's going to be a mind
blower and from here on out guys it's
about putting my foot down and making
videos on a regular basis doing live
streams every single week getting my
brain condition into like grinding out
like I once did I have a number of
things lined up that are going to uh I
think will be my best yet I'll hold off
on telling you what topics but I will
give you a hint whole shifts and other
things I'm going to be making comments a
video on ball back and explain to you
all the explanations from the mainstream
on how they say this is completed and
you will see that it's utterly debunked
so with that being said let me close up
here on YouTube and continue over on
Rumble uh let me see if I can do this
on my own
let's see here
okay this was created on YouTube
I wonder if
let's see
all right guys see you see you over on
Rumble right now click the link in the
description